à stratège stratège et demi à quelques
heures du dépôt de la demande de remise
en liberté de leur client
les conseils de johnatan d'avaler suit
la contre attaque des parties civiles
trois mois après sa mise en cause qui
l'avait alors qualifié de risible
le beau frère du prévenu demande une
confrontation
aujourd'hui on a quand même le sentiment
que grégory gay est dans une dynamique
réellement de combat entre guillemets
succube permet depuis ce qu'il est on va
mettre les points sur les lignes à l
écart des propos qu'il a pu exprimer
dans un journal local
donc oui les pats pas si serein et pas
si apaisé que ça par rapport aux dates à
la dernière version de nate henn d'aval
la manoeuvre intervient tel pour contrer
la demande de remise en liberté pour le
conseil de grégory gay il était surtout
temps de changer ton son client et son
épouse envisageant par ailleurs de
porter plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse
la persistance des avocats de johnatan
d'aval à répandre cette odieuse théorie
sur des plateaux télévisés nous pousse à
agir
depuis trois mois les nécessaires
vérifications n'ont pas été réalisés
nous prenons l'initiative de crever
l'abcès
johnatan d'aval se prêtera t-il à
l'exercice de la confrontation rien ne
l'y oblige
pour à tour mari d'eva c est fou
meurtrier puis victime malgré lui d'un
complot familial l'homme intrigue deux
experts psychologues et psychiatres
l'ont rencontré qui décrivent une
personnalité déterminée colérique avec
une propension à la toute-puissance
quelqu'un de jeu sites dangereux sur le
plan criminologique un expert
psychologue il n'est pas là pour dire
quelle est la vérité il est pas là pour
dire si une version est crédible ou
n'est pas crédible c'est pas un
détecteur de mensonges il est pas là
pour avoir des conclusions qui sont
péremptoire pourquoi il est manipulateur
ça va falloir me l'expliquer pourquoi il
serait pervers narcissique ça il va
falloir me l'expliquer et là on n'est
plus dans une simple discussion
unilatérales ou n'affirme des choses
lorsque il faudra s'expliquer devant une
cour d'assises il faudra que ce soit
charpenté et argumenté la save est
difficile pas pour nous
la énième version de johnatan d'aval sur
la mort de son épouse tire-t-elle la
route
après le beau frère les parents d'alexia
réclament à leur tour une confrontation
avec celui qui demeure à ce jour le seul
mis en examen du dossier